I'm trying to watch three porns in my
life in my whole life I've tried to
watch three pointers I've never been
able to make it through one and my
husband said to me Jack you know
whatever finish to pour don't worry
about oh that resonates well here's
something I'm willing to admit to you I
still read some romance novels it's
still happening occasionally read a
romance novel yeah there's some silence
hey guys
I tell you something people get on stage
all over the world comics do and they
talk about their love of porn and drugs
and audiences are like interesting
interesting fascinating I get up I admit
that I occasionally read some poorly
written prose and there is some judgment
I do not watch porn because I was born 1
million years old and every time I've
tried to watch porn I end up yelling at
the television you should call your mom
just call her she would love to hear
from you just call her
it's very hard to get off on that
you